please pitch up those pants a little
higher i got a very tight skirt on
because we have the amazing jaleel white
[Applause]
oh my god i've been so excited to talk
to you but last weekend i am obsessed
with the cnn shows um you know like the
history of and
this was the history of the sitcom and
there was the whole thing about you you
did an interview
and one of the things that really caught
my attention was
you went on to that show
and can you please tell that story
because it like it was different than
what i would have guessed
yeah no we listened i i got a different
start than you drew i got different i
was just uh i was just a kid trying to
make money to go to college and uh i
went on an audition i had braces on my
teeth
the audition was to play the nerd most
of the people wanted to actually go out
for the role of the cute guy that laura
wanted to go to the dance with and it
was just me and three other boys and i
really wanted this job because i wanted
a sega genesis and my parents would let
me go to toys r us and get whatever i
wanted if i got this job and that's how
it happened
but
your character
something happened because of you what
happened yeah the show was saved
i didn't know you know and unbeknownst
to me um it was really special night
though when we taped the show because i
remember a fraternity came that night
and i'll never forget these guys i
always wish i could find them and thank
them because they would chant we want
the nerd in all the scenes that i wasn't
in uh during the live taping and it's
funny because back then i didn't have a
parking space by the stage i had to park
in in the big structure with all with
the audience so i actually walked back
to the to the structure with the very
guys who were chanting and ultimately
got me the bad job
okay so you were 12 years old there then
and now your daughter is 12. have you
talked to her about like how you grew up
oh gosh she has no interest in how i
grew up i i i showed her a cassette tape
once and i was like this is what we used
to listen to music on and before i could
even get my explanation out she just
taken the whole thing out and said this
is stupid so that's easy tell her you
take a pencil and you stick it in the
middle and twist it
she's like this is stupid my daughter
even when i try to tell her she's a good
dancer she's like dad it's tick tock i'm
like okay all right no argue in here
well speaking of former child stars and
children of a certain age your podcast
that is incredibly successful called
ever after
is so successful you've pulled an urkel
once again
that and a seed grew into a garden uh
your podcast is now being made into a tv
series
why did you come up with this idea you
know i just i always see bad press about
former child actors and the truth of the
matter is there's a lot more that turn
out like you but maybe not even
necessarily as famous but doctors
lawyers and and it's all dependent on
coming from a good family background and
i was like who's telling these stories
um and i just started going through my
own phone really and from people like
brian austin green to seth green to maya
bialik
melissa john hart i just started calling
up my friends danica mckellar and they
were all like yeah jay will come on so
it made it an easy show for me to book
during pandemic uh i was literally going
to my buddy's uh with my producer's
airstream in the front of his house and
i'm i'm doing the podcast and it was
just it was it was positive and it was
it gave people a lot of insight into uh
into the reality of of uh of what it is
to being a child performer and not
necessarily the nasty headline that says
oh you know somebody got caught on drugs
or something like that
i mean i
i definitely thank you for putting on a
show like that because it's true
some of us made it out okay and i i
really thank you for that jaleel i
really do
that's a huge commentary coming from you
like you you were definitely one of my
my wishlist guests like way up at the
top i grew up watching you on movies
like fire starters so i get to bring up
your old stuff too and that was like one
of my favorite films as a kid it was one
of the first movies that you saw a kid
carry um so i very much grew up watching
you
first of all i'm so honored and i also
love that your podcast is called ever
after which is a film that i did that
changed my life forever um and i have
been such a fan of yours that's why i
was looking forward to talking to you
because i grew up with you
and i just think the world of you and
it's really nice to grow up with you
thank you
[Music]